welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy that would never be seen in
an invisible jet
and it's time to get out your massive
19-incher because wonder woman 84
is now out online if you haven't seen
the other 83 movies before it then don't
worry because we're gonna be breaking it
all down
pointing out some of the easter eggs and
giving our thoughts whilst also
providing some crap jokes to accompany
the piece
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you think gal gadot is hot enough
to make kevin feige say all hell dark
side and please subscribe for videos
like this each and every day
merry christmas to everyone ho ho ho now
let's get into the breakdown
okay so the film starts off with a
flashback to diana's childhood
in what seems to be a couple of years
after she was given permission to train
at an olympic themed games event she
shows that she's far ahead of the adults
and at one point dives off a platform in
a way that's a clear call back to the
first film in which she did something
similar
not long after the character falls off
her horse and she takes a shortcut in
order to get ahead
it looks like there might not be a
punishment for this but upon reaching
the finish line she's disqualified from
the race by her aunt antiope
and a move that's certain to ruin
christmas now though seemingly
disconnected from what's to come
this scene actually sets up a big deem
that's laced throughout the movie
from the introduction we get the idea
that if one is willing to cheat and take
shortcuts in order to get what they want
then that will lead to them losing a lot
in the long run and it reflects the
general motif of the dream stone and
maxwell lord
the dreamstone is pretty much the
macguffin of the movie and juxtaposing
diana's lasso of truth
we learn that it's powered by lies they
have an excellent way of bringing the
beautiful lies theme over from batman v
superman in order to tie this film in
with the greater universe
and it's definitely one of the more
intriguing plot devices in the dc eu
when holding it one can wish for what
their heart desires
however it has a monkey poor effect and
though it gives the bearer whatever they
want
it also takes something in return even
the guy who just wishes for a coffee
burns his mouth and yeah some sometimes
just be careful what you wish for
now lord gets it at one point in the
film and his greed makes him wish to
become it
and what's basically the comic book
movie equivalent of i wish for a million
wishes
lord is very much based on donald trump
and whilst i don't want to go into my
personal opinion on him
as far as the film goes it clearly
portrays him as someone who promises a
lot
but in turn takes more than he gives
lord is a con man
a television personality who tells
people what they want to hear
and he works his way up to the
presidency it's about as subtle as henry
cavill's mustache
but the reality of the situation is that
when everyone gets what they want
everyone loses out fueled by a childhood
in which his father made him feel poor
and insignificant
he's come to believe that materialism
equals power and that the life he's
always dreamed of
should be his number at the cost he was
called a loser
and doesn't want to appear like one to
his own son who becomes
central to bringing him back from the
brink now all the metaphors aside
i really appreciated the film's tie
backs to the source material
and in the comics he originally started
off as someone without powers
but over the years he's evolved into a
character that could influence
people telepathically this brought a
nosebleed switch to becomes present in
the movie
and the film very much condenses his
lung and rich history into one arc
pascal provides one of the best
performances in the movie
and what's crazy is that he actually
featured in the failed wonder woman
project from a couple of years back so i
glad he got his wish to finally sort it
all out they also have an appearance
from simon stagg
who you may know from the arkham knight
game and dc comics
the film obviously takes place on the
most part in 1984
and we pick up to find diana helping
where she can whilst
also remaining anonymous she takes out
security cameras
doesn't brand people and though it's not
a foolproof explanation
we can understand why bruce and bbs had
never heard of her
diana has very much lived a life of
solitude since the death of steve trevor
and though we see that she kept in touch
with her old unit it appears that many
of them have passed on
we see photos of the chief freeing jews
in the holocaust
an etter who also took a boat ride with
diana to what i believe
might be metropolis clark of course rode
across the harbour to gotham and bbs
but i i might be reaching yeah won't be
the first time happening but it's
christmas yeah let me off
now diana stares longingly at planes
that echo how steve passed
and she's very much still grieving so i
hope no one is a jerk and tells her to
get over it
though she's often found dianing alone
it's not too long before she crosses
paths with barbara minerva
the pair discover the dreamstone after
it's brought in from a heist
and when holding it they both make a
wish diana wishes that steve would
return
whilst barbara wishes to be like diana
which of course brings a lot with it
steve is brought back through possessing
another man and initially
all diana sees is him however after
concentrating she sees the true person
within
and this allows steve to exist without
raising questions amongst other people
although they are together as we
mentioned earlier there is a trade-off
and she loses her powers
barbara gains some but in return she
loses her warmth in humanity
and and slowly becomes a bit of a jerk
now the vulmar aspect is very similar to
superman too
as in that clock wish to have a normal
life with the one he loved
but in turn he lost his abilities i
think dc is very much paying homage to
that movie especially throughout this
and in my opinion yeah it works quite
well
now whereas in the first film diana was
very much the fish out of water
here it's steve and they even do a call
back to the trying on outfits scene from
that film
with some updated gear for the boy
there's also a train moment similar to
how there was in the original movie
and they are clearly referencing what
came before with the callbacks
now lord becomes the dream stone and he
works his way back from financial rune
diana and steve attempt to take it back
and they bring the invisible jet across
in a brilliant way channeling the same
magic that her father zeus used to hide
their mascara from sight
she turns the plane invisible and the
pair arrive at egypt for a big action
scene
they're defeated and this is when diana
discovers she's weakened
and this is where she learns about the
truth of the stone
they realize that if one renounces their
wish that things can return to normal
but barbara has other ideas and doesn't
want to fade into the background once
more
i love how she pretty much fit the 80s
stereotype of the nerd girl turned hot
and she actually makes for a brilliant
buddy in my opinion
now when steve and diana try and
confront lord again at the white house
barbara attacks them and he's able to
get away with the influence of the
president
and access to his special communications
device
this global broadcast satellite allows
every tv on the planet to be taken over
so that lord is actually able to reach
out and touch all those on earth
you know i'm somewhat of a scientist
myself and i had no idea how this
actually worked but
apparently because the particles touched
people
lord could be connected with them here
just don't ask
now steve realizes that the world is
doomed if he doesn't make diana renounce
her wish
and they do have a heartbreaking
farewell in which he shouts goodbye to
him
before soaring off into the air her
flight here very much resembles clarkson
man of steel
and in some ways i see her doing this in
order to connect with steve through the
thing he loved
diana goes and gets the golden asteria
armor and she travels to take down lord
which is when we discover that barbara
has transformed herself into an apex
predator with the help of lord's
abilities
everyone getting their wish causes the
world to descend into chaos
it's one hell of a finale that still
looks better than 2020
we get a great cheetah vs wonder woman
showdown whilst law grants people's
wishes across the world
taking things from them in order to make
himself more powerful
diana manages to bust cheer up and she
ends up confronting lord
in what is a climactic ending lord
promises to give her steve back if she
stops
and though she wants it more than her
heart can bear she does accept that he's
gone
she knows everything has a price and
that she isn't willing to pay it
in order to be happy reaching out to the
world she pleased with them to renounce
their wishes to a beautiful lie
saying that you cannot have it all you
can only have the truth
which should be enough everyone has
things that only they have
and to want more is to be greedy which
will only lead to the downfall of others
she puts the lasso of truth around lords
that he can no longer lie to the world
and make them promises that he can't
keep
in doing so the power of truth from the
lasso also goes through him
and into the communications device where
it shines across the world
showing humanity what it can be lord 2
sees the truth of the matter
and that he's destroyed the planet put
his son in danger
and thus he renounces his wish meaning
that he can be with his child
this pattern of behavior happens across
the world and things
revert back to how they were almost like
someone flew backwards around the world
now lord returns to his son and admits
that he made mistakes
and is a bit of a loser but that his son
will never have to make a wish
in order to have him love him he knows
he's nothing to be proud of but
that he will try his best his son fires
back by saying he loves him
unconditionally and i'm not crying it's
it's the deadbeat dads that are crying
right now
now the movie ends with diana at
christmas witnessing the holiday cheer
whilst getting smacked in the back of
the head by stupid brats with
snowballs the ma i hate them the man who
had his body taken over by steve shows
up
and uh you know this should have been a
bit more awkward because the banked but
it was quite a nice moment
although they don't hook up he says that
she made his day
and the movie entered this thinking that
diana could finally let steve go and one
day be happy again
like you wanted it to be we see a world
filled with joy
and celebration and it feels like the
perfect message of hope that we need in
2020.
a child's balloon floats up and anna
looks to the sky
much like how she did with the airplanes
that reminded her of steve
but this time she's happy and accepting
that things have changed
that ends the movie but because it's a
comic book one you know we're getting a
post-credits scene
and in that we see asteria being played
by none other than linda carter
throughout the movie we heard legends of
this figure and the last time that
asteria was seen by the amazonians
she was holding off spartans in what
could be a zack snyder 300 tribute
since then diana believed that she may
be out in civilization
lying low much like how she was and this
is confirmed here
hysteria says that she's been doing this
a long time
and by that she likely means saving
people and not dressing up as
wonder woman i've already done a full
breakdown on this scene and how the
cameo came about
and also the ins and outs of how it was
teased at dc fandom
however in that video i mistakenly said
that i think this
teased towards the next film taking
place in the 80s
with the pair meeting up since then
paddy jenkins has came forward and
clarified that the third wonder woman
will actually be taking place in the
present after the events of justice
league
so we finally know what happens next now
though that's the case
it doesn't negate my theory that carter
or rather asteria
will become somewhat of a mentor figure
to diana i think due to the characters
both being pretty much ageless
but they can set it at any time period
and have their pair still work together
going forward i think that diana will
track her down and we will learn the
truth about where she's been
and what it is that she's been up to
since disappearing
they do a great job of making her seem
like gal from behind
i think this has been done to suggest
just how close the two will be linked
whatever year it's set in i'm still
hyped
and i have to say that i really enjoyed
wonder woman 1984.
i've been lucky enough to see the film
twice now and for me it's better than
the original movie
which i think was let down by a weak
third act that relied too heavily on cgi
here it's more about the message and
there's a big feeling of hope
which is strongly needed in 2020 wonder
woman is a great period piece
i think every actor does a lot with what
they're given
i had a lot of fun with it and for me
it's probably in the top three dcu
movies
with man of steel and the extended
edition of batman v superman
maybe maybe ranking above it i am happy
to watch it again though
and it gets an 8.5 out of 10.
now don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film
the links to our socials are in the
description you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
below and as a thank you you get videos
like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the post
credits scene which sort of goes into
more detail on on what we think is going
to be happening
anyway that pretty much brings the video
to a close thank you for sitting through
it
and again i hope you have a very merry
christmas you take care of yourself for
the rest of the year
and i i love you goodbye peace